okay sie nicht da bist du so weiter
verschenken wir für die reisenden
hey du siehst doch aufsätze interesse an
einer eisenkette tier stirbt einfach
services und herzlich willkommen zu
einem video in dem ich heute
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen rating werde
denn immer heute die folgenden spielen
erstmal jump liegt das wird der
fachkundige betrachter bereits bemerkt
haben
wir machen heute das folgende wir zählen
die anzahl meiner job fehlt schritt
nummer eins am ende
sobald das dran fertig ist teilen wir
die anzahl meiner jump fans durch zwei
dann bekommen wir andere zahl aus und
diese zahl ist die zahl meiner besten
items dich abgeben muss so wenn wir von
oben runter und sagen was das beste
alles da mal die akkus oder sowas
mangeln dass wir das beiseite
da muss die die boots wegschmeißen und
so weiter mit schwertern displays und
jetzt wird es gab schon richtig tricky
ich will natürlich keinen einzigen job
ferien haben also idealerweise habe ich
keinen job fällt wenn ich einen job
hätte gut damit lässt sich 205 wir
runden aber auf nummer sicher nicht zum
spaß hier
genau das heißt wenn ich einen einzigen
job mache in diesem ganzen job dran
werde ich auf jeden fall items abgeben
müssen und ich sage dazu wird kommen ist
einzige was ich machen kann ist einfach
jetzt mich jetzt nur ein bisschen mehr
aufs jump'n'run zu konzentrieren und
nicht zu verhehlen dass ich ein problem
leute da müssen wir drauf kommen
erstmalig auszuloten
man müsste eigentlich da oben drauf
kommen ein roman das hätte theoretisch
gereicht
okay das ist unser erster job fällt
jetzt haben es geschafft und weiter ein
jumper hamburg mit nicht dass ich am
ende betrüge auch ein durchaus tricky
modul ihr habe ich auch schon mal eine
menge fans gezahlt den gewissen runden
wo ich einfach die ganze zeit hier hing
wie sie es heute aussieht eigentlich
recht flüssig aus gerade gar nicht so
schlecht es könnte vielleicht ohne job
funktionieren das funktioniert unser job
verlor wir bleiben bei einem job fällt
jetzt hier ganz vorsichtig nicht im
busch sich verwirren lassen wir schauen
durch den burschen durch erkennen die
wahrheit jetzt der zweite job tut mir an
sich erstmal nicht weh weil man 12 ist
05 wird aufgerundet auf 1 2 durch zwei
ist auch ein das heißt macht jetzt
erstmal kein unterschied kommt dann aber
der dritte
stehen wir bei 3 durch zwei das ist 15
und da muss ich auch schon auf runden
und zwei wegschmeißen jetzt wird ja wohl
komplett check point was leider bis
gesehen nicht einfach eiskalt zurück der
letzte block ein jumper nach wie vor
auch das war richtig los gerade ja passt
man warte bis mir mal den äußersten rand
einmal kommt aus suchen okay gut zu
wissen unter umfeld nach wie vor kann
man das reicht und ich sage das reicht
und ich sage das reicht soll das sind
alles module die bisher machbar waren
das hier ist an sich auch machbar würde
ich sagen kann man ohne job verschaffen
wenn es läuft hier soweit alles gut okay
sagte übrigens heute ich hab snapshot ne
va plus solle
seit heute habe ich snap chat wenn ihr
mir da folgen wollte spacenet also es
geht wie man youtube name und ein snap
sn/ap pt also 2 da für mich ich hab
keine ahnung wie es funktioniert ich
hoffe ich poste nicht irgendeinen sinn
den leuten nicht sehen sollen weil ich
das ding ich teile das nur als info der
name seiner beschreibung vorbeischauen
wollte ersten ziel gegners im ziel
das werk ist mit dem nein nein mein
service teams nein 33 an facebook meine
zwei besten reisen wo sich abgeben
die sind sage ich mal der eisenbahn und
die eisen estate warte jetzt ab warte
warte braucht warte warte warte vorliege
lag nicht so durch die gegend alter
schwede laufen von mir und zu sagen wir
wollen etwas gutes so caspar konnten
unser eisenreich das war verschenken
ganz wichtig und wir wollen die iron
chest pain verschenken alter das tut
einem in der seele weh
als passionierter jumping spieler die
items weg geben zu müssen
so kommt erstmal ein bisschen wo die
gegner sind so zeigt das fernsehen das
im fernsehen dass die fans ihn haben
drei gene fans gemacht
richtig oder ich verzeihe ich glaube es
von 3m fans heißt zweitens mehr abgeben
an wen an ihn er hat mir ich danke schön
dass mich gehasst kommt ich dachte ich
dass hier ein eisen und wieso warte ich
eigentlich ich glaube dass japan haben
glaube ich mein baum kommt den ihr du
machen wenn man eigentlich sollte er das
eigentlich ich dachte ich komme zurück
laut müsse auf jeden fall brauchen noch
mal die eisen jazz plate verschenken und
zwar können wir dem erst mal ein paar
ein mitgehen
der braucht die nicht sage ich ihr
braucht die einfach nicht aber der
andere hat vielleicht schon du okay wer
will so du neue pvp hier
da nimmt er will sie nicht nur noch die
sp doch er nimmt sie als wieder
hingeworfen
okay sie nicht er müsse weiter
verschenken wir für diesen test werden
hey du siehst doch aussetzte interesse
an einer eisenkette wasser fällt und
stirbt einfach
juni ich wollte was schenken empfiehlt
sich einfach selbst alte was war das
denn und newel einer der ein bisschen
was machen das ganz niki wir drucken
japans emmental
okay okay mein freund bleibt stehen ich
habe eine eisentür licht hier guck ich
bin da hatte da nehmen sie nehmen sie
doch nehmen sie doch nicht mich töten
nicht mich töten soll sich alsbald
nehmen was zur hölle ist mit den leuten
los ich will einfach nur ein item
verschenken niemand nimmt oder ist ein
eisenbahn ist es vielleicht der den ich
am anfang der runde verschenkte wo es
auch die eisenstädter hier mit der kiste
verschwunden
alles klar dann würde ich sagen was
unser zweitbestes item wenn wir die
eisenbahn jetzt nicht mehr verschenken
können weil die küste die geschluckt hat
was unsere seite ok den eisenbahnern
müsse auf jeden fall wieder verschenken
und den chan chan tatsächlich auch
ziemlich gut ok verschenken den
entscheid und in eisen waren donny pvp
ok nimmt sehr gut sehr gut das freut
mich
wahrscheinlich denken anders über den
team der hab ich doch gerade mir
weggeholt der kleine schneller wm-ok ein
halber hier und jetzt habe ich mit
dessen reisen mitnehmen hier zeigt
barbara ja wohl sehr schön das heißt ich
habe doch wieder reisen stellt nämlich
somit bin ich aber ich glaube hier oben
versteckt sich einer kann das sein
zurzeit sitzt locker im haus gezählt
müssen wir eine hausdurchsuchung machen
ich habe das gefühl hier drin versteckt
sich eine die tür ist zu dass es keine
dietz dafür dass er nicht doch jemand
ist der genau da ist nämlich der kompass
lügt nicht
ok den logan aber deutlich stellt wird
man keine chance für ihn passt cookie 10
man darf nicht ihm ich denke ich team
jetzt mit ihm
ich weiß ich musste aber altes
verschenken leute manchmal muss man
einfach items verschenken
ok ok ja gut wir könnten auch diese
runde theoretisch obwohl also bestens zu
schenken müssen noch gewinnen die pvp
hat nur noch ein leben über den
irgendwie weg holen können dann flugs
opa die akkus so er will sich seiten
verstecken
oktober überraschend wir können
überraschen verwickelt deren die erste
first week das passt werk das könnte
passen
das könnte passen ja wohl und wir haben
ihn wir haben ihn
alter schwede was der volksmund hat nein
nein nein
1 geholt wurde
wir haben zumindest mal die die abos
mitgenommen malta hat mich jetzt voll
überrascht man ich hätte noch viel mehr
zeit gebraucht jetzt fehlt mir einfach
eiskalten stick guckt euch das an leute
ich hab zwei eisen ich könnte graphen
günstig ist es okay hier raus da vorne
sein als jetzt die jazzband geschafft
das war nicht das was war denn versteckt
hat den hunger schnell sagt zack zack
zack zack zack zack ist auch weg da der
stick safestick eiskalt hat sich gelohnt
mann
ich dachte mir schon was eine typ haben
was uns hilft aber er hat sticks heißt
wir können jetzt obwohl wir am anfang
ein eisenbahn waren abgeben mussten
können wir uns jetzt einfach weil wir
zwei eisenwaren haben auf einmal ein
schwert kräften wir haben das eisen
schwert und jetzt will ich sagen muss
den letzten gegner da komm runter kommt
ja komm runter oder sonst komme ich hoch
komm runter
los los los ich will mein altes wir dann
ja auch probieren jetzt kommt doch hab
ich soviel angst ja 30 sekunden gewinne
ich komm runter schnell besser ok go
jetzt für dich büro
da ist es frisch frist partners
gestorben in response to respond das
wird es nicht mehr reichen für ihn ist
jetzt da oben er kommt runter zehn
sekunden
und wie ging nochmal hin gehen wir noch
mal mit und ohne gewonnen sehr schön
das gibt 1 gg sehr schön wie sich das
death match entwickelt hat mit einem
eisenbahnen gestartet den verschenkt
dann am ende zwei gehabt und daraus
verkraftet das würde ich sagen ich hoffe
ich mich verzählt bei den jockeys lass
mich in den kommentaren wissen wie es
ist und bis zum nächsten video